independence is a very useful property
whenever it is true we can break up
complicated situations into simpler ones
in particular we can do separate
calculations for each piece of a given
model and then combine the results we
are going to look at an application of
this idea into the analysis of
reliability of a system that consists of
independent units so we have a system
that consists of a number let's say n of
units and each one of the units can be
up or down and it's going to be up with
a certain probability P I furthermore we
will assume that unit failures are
independent intuitively what we mean is
that failure of some of the units does
not affect the probability that some of
the other units will fail if we want to
be more formal we might proceed as
follows we could define an event UI to
be the event that the 8th unit is up and
then make the assumption that the events
u1 u2 and so on up to u n if we have n
units are independent alternatively we
could define events F I where event fi
is the event that the eighth unit is
down or that it has failed and we could
assume that the unit that the events F I
are independent but we do not really
need a separate assumption as a
consequence of the assumption that the U
is are independent one can argue that
the F Phi's are also independent how do
we know that this is the case if we were
dealing with just two units then this is
a fact that we have already proved
a little earlier we did prove that if
two events are independent then their
complements are also independent now
that we're dealing with multiple events
here a general number and how do we
argue one approach would be to be formal
and start from the definition of
Independence of the you events and that
definition gives us a number of formulas
then manipulate those formulas to prove
the conditions that are required in
order to check that the events fi are
independent this is certainly possible
although it is a bit tedious however the
approach we will be taking in situations
like this one is that we will use the
intuitive understanding that we have of
what independence means so independence
in this context means that whether some
units are up and down does not change
the probabilities that some of the other
units will be up or down and by taking
that interpretation independence of the
events that units are up is essentially
the same as independence or on the units
have failed so we take this implication
for granted and now we move to do some
calculations for specific systems
consider a particular system that
consists of three components and we will
say that the system is up if there
exists a path from the left to the right
that consists of units that are up so in
this case for the system to be up we
need all three components to be up and
we proceed as follows the probability
that the system is up this is the event
that the first unit is up and the second
unit is up and the third unit is up and
now we use independence to argue that
this is equal to the probability that
the first is unit is up times the
probability that the second unit is up
times the probability that the third
unit is up and in the notation that we
have introduced this is
P 1 times P 2 times P 3 now let us
consider a different system in this
system we will say that the system is up
again if there exists a path from the
left to the right that consists of units
that are up in this particular case the
system will be up as long as at least
one of those 3 components are up we
would like again to calculate the
probability that the system is up and
the system will be up as long as either
unit 1 is up or unit 2 is up or unit 3
is up how do we continue from here we
cannot use independence readily because
independence refers to probabilities of
intersection of events whereas here we
have a union how do we turn a union into
an intersection this is what the
Morgan's laws allow us to do and
involves taking compliments
instead of using formally de Morgan's
laws let's just argue directly let us
look at this event that unit 1 fails and
unit 2 fails and unit 3 fails what is
the relation between this event and the
event that we have here there are
complements why is that either
all units fail which is this event or
there exists at least one unit which is
up so since this event is the complement
of that event
this means that their probabilities must
add to 1 and therefore we have this
relation and now we're in better shape
because we can use the independence of
the events F to write this as the 1
minus the product of the probabilities
that each one of the units fails and
with the notation that we have
introduced who using the P is this
as follows the probability that unit one
fails is one minus the probability that
it is up similarly for the second unit
one minus the probability that it is up
then the same for the third unit so we
have derived a formula that tells us the
reliability the probability that the
system of this kind is up in terms of
the probabilities of each of its
individual components you will have an
opportunity to deal with more examples
of this kind a little more complicated
in the problem that follows and even
more complicated in one of the
problem-solving videos that we will have
available for you